thank you very much for coming everyone
hopefully you're here for
this talk I titled it
neotronin why write a brand new dos for
arm in Rust it's trying to squeeze all
of the keywords into the title but
really you can
we're going to spend the next hour
taking a taking a romp taking a hike
taking a Gallop through Computing
history we're going to ask ourselves
what is a computer what is an operating
system and then at the end I'll talk
about why I wrote a new one
so a little bit about me to start
um so my name is Jonathan palant I'm an
embedded systems engineer have been for
25 years at this point
um done a lot of programming languages
in the past started with basic turbo
Pascal did some modular two
um I may have written some tickle once
upon a time I don't put that on the
slide
um mainly these days I'm a rust
programmer and rust trainer and I work
at Ferris systems based out of Berlin we
do training courses
and we do rust-based consultancy
um
all of my stuff is mainly on GitHub
where you will find me slash the jpster
you'll find me talking a lot on Twitter
about this and other nonsense projects
involving old computers uh I came to
Twitter late so I could only get slash
the real jpster there is a the jpster on
Twitter that's not me and this project
exists at its own little GitHub Pages
um and there you will even find these
slides these slides are written in
markdown you are free to Fork them
um share them whenever you want so if
you want to find any little references
you can look at the GitHub and you can
get the material okay
so what I want to do today is to
introduce this sort of operating system
I'm writing and talking about why I
wanted to write it but to do that I need
to set the scene and talk about the
other operating systems that already
exist because why not use one of those
is a perfectly valid question criticism
but to do that I think it's useful to
talk about the history of the operating
system and to do that we really need to
cover off first and foremost what is an
operating system what do we mean when we
use that term I'd like this to be an
interactive talk confession I did
originally present this at Accu where I
had 90 minutes which is why this has
been moved up from a a hike through to a
Gallop through Computing history because
there's a lot of computing history to
cover but I'd like this to be
interactive so
um in the spirit of the of the the
Boeing keynote we had yesterday
um every time I mention a computer
company that is sadly no longer with us
whether having been acquired or folded
through crass mismanagement
um just
punch your fist in the air and we'll say
skull okay it's just in memory of of
computer companies that have sadly
departed now there will be there'll be
some familiar names in here for for some
of you
okay but let's talk about what an
operating system is let's even Define
the term OS operating system
not to be confused with DOs a Disk
Operating System often pronounced dos
now there was a very famous dos written
by Microsoft when I say dos I don't
necessarily mean that one I mean sort of
operating systems that work with disks
in a more wider sense if I mean the
Microsoft DOS I'll say so
um
there is also the real-time operating
system
we're not really talking about those at
all those belong to the set of embedded
systems and this talk is not about
embedded systems I mean the PC PCB I've
got looks like an embedded system but
it's not I've tried to make it a general
purpose computer and I think that's a
different thing
so what does an operating system or a
Disk Operating System need to do well I
think it needs to do four things it
needs to run applications run on a
computer manage some files probably on
disk hence the name and give you some
kind of portability so I think we will
agree that is an application that is
anyone recognize that one
you've all used it yeah it's Microsoft
Word for Mac OS it's got things we
recognize for applications there's
someone who had a window with some some
controls on it there's a menu system
there's a status bar at the bottom that
is an application
is this an application
I'd say it is yeah it's processing user
input it's providing some output
still got a menu and a status bar this
is Microsoft Word five for dos now the
key thing I want to get across here is
don't think about applications
purely through the lens of how you
currently interact with them
they're a concept that exists beyond
that it extends into the past we have
had programs and applications for a long
time and they didn't look like the ones
you use now it's an app on your iPhone
this is arguably an app as is this this
is Microsoft Word version one for MS-DOS
resolution is slightly lower we still
have a sort of a status bar at the
bottom and we definitely don't sort of
have any menu system and you're going to
be I think exclusively uh pretty much
exclusively using the keyboard although
there is a pretty low res mouse cursor
on there
is this an application
so this is the game Wordle
that someone is running on an ASR 33
teletype so there is some kind of mini
computer system in the in the background
perhaps we don't know what's connected
to the teletype but it's connected over
some serial link and
you're in Visual Studio code like brand
new text editor on your brand new
Macintosh
and you select the option to say open
Terminal
you ever wondered why it's called a
terminal
or it's sometimes known as a teletype
this is a tele type it is a tele
typewriter it types things according to
stuff that comes in over a cable from
long away why is this a terminal
because as with the railway line the
terminal is at the end of the line
so there is a mini computer somewhere
with multiple serial cables coming out
and the terminal sits at the end of each
line this machine receives bytes
probably an ASCII and it prints them and
anything you type on the keyboard goes
back down the line that is exactly how
your terminal in Visual Studio code
works these concepts are not new they
exist
from the old times
okay so we have some sense of what an
application is we get some sense that we
shouldn't be constrained by specific
visual form but there is some sense of
input some output and some storage
so a Disk Operating System runs on a
computer
what is a computer well a computer has a
processing unit a CPU that executes some
instructions we tell it what to do and
it does it it doesn't judge us for this
it just does what it's told to do and we
have this idea of registers these little
places where we can store data
temporarily
but that's not enough we need some
memory we need more storage
memory is I like to think of it as
the locker room at your local swimming
pool there are a num a series of
numbered boxes you can open Locker
number 25 and you can put shoes in it
you can lock it it's in there later you
can look in Locker number 25 and it will
still contain shoes
basically what Ram is it's just a place
where we can store numbers
we have this idea of volatile and
non-volatile memory I would argue
all memory is volatile
it is simply a matter of time scale
if you have a computer from the early
1980s you may find it's not working
anymore because the ROM chips have died
those ROM chips were Technically
non-volatile when they were during the
warranty period but as time goes on
these things fail
hard disks how many of you have built a
hard disk out of the cupboard after 20
years and gone I wonder if that backup
still works I have maybe not
but then we need some input and output
right so we can if we had this beautiful
black obsidian monolith with a power
input no LEDs no buttons it just hummed
you can see the computer is running he's
doing good work
what work is it doing I don't know it
doesn't have any input or output
therefore we assume it it's correct
right that that is not a useful computer
that is a space heater a computer must
have input and output we must be able to
give it
commands and this is usually display
keyboard storage devices communication
yeah we're all familiar with this
um computers often pretend that their
input and output is actually just memory
there's just special regions of memory
you know a locker where you put the
shoes in and it's not really a locker
because there's someone on the other
side who opens the other door and looks
in goes shoes great I'll swap those and
you can have you know bag of sweets in
return next time you look in the locker
the bag of sweets has appeared this is
bizarre this this Locker is not
functioning like a locker some memory
does not function like memory it is
actually input and output
uh I think really great this is a
computer
IBM system 360. we're looking
1965 at this point 64k of RAM
um it's an 8-bit system it's clocked at
one megahertz
but it takes eight clock Cycles to fetch
something from a register
and this sort of makes sense when you
realize the processor is not a chip the
processor is a series of at least a
dozen
printed circuit boards that exist in the
cabinet on the left so a register is not
like a couple of transistors in a
silicon chip that's right next to the
pro to the arithmetic unit it's like the
registers are on this board and the
arithmetic unit is on this board and
there's a lot of cable in between the
two
so you only get about 35 000
instructions per second
I think a Casio wrist watch would
comfortably outrun that we've got two I
think maybe three five megabyte disk
drives these are the sort of the big
things on the right hand side and there
is a tele type at the front so that's
where the operator sits down and gives
it input and output
cost about a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars
this I think you will agree is a PC it
is d
IBM PC 1982
clock speeds have gone up a bit
obviously the processor is much smaller
it's much cheaper system this cost you
about fifteen hundred dollars
64k of ram again
um floppy drives were optional on the
IBM PC does anyone know what an IBM PC
would do if you bought the base spec
without floppy drives does anyone know
what it would do
it's 1982. it does what every computer
in 1982 would do it boots to a basic
prompt
this thing is just a Commodore 64 except
it's three times the price that's really
what's going on here
um but it turns out the floppy disks
were kind of useful and the the
operating system that was supplied with
it turned out to be kind of popular for
reasons that I find annoying it also has
somewhere to plug in a cassette deck
right so floppy drives are optional you
just plug in a tape drive
how many of you have looked put your
hands up if you've ever loaded software
from a cassette tape now we've got some
hands going up that's what a PC should
be
question is this a computer
well it's got a processor and it's got
some memory argue it's a bit light on
the input output
I think it sort of depends what you plug
into it I would contend you can turn it
into a computer
but you probably have to make a circuit
board like that
to plug it into it is of course so much
faster than the IBM PC 256k Ram
two megabytes of of flash storage
two processors running at 133 megahertz
and they are 32-bit processors not
16-bit
and the whole board costs four dollars
the main processor chip costs 75 cents
with the world we live in is wild in
terms of access to computing power
which led me to a question if this is a
computer
but it cost you fifteen hundred dollars
why isn't this a computer when it is
more powerful it has more capacity
maybe we can make it a computer
so we've talked about applications uh
they run on a computer what else does a
Dos do would it manages files on disk
and as we know disks are called disks
because they are round you know I guess
it comes from the Greek you think of it
discus they are
round
um okay these days discs aren't disks
but they do a very good job of
pretending to be discs this is obviously
an m.2 flash SSD when you load from your
disk drive it's probably these days just
memory chips
in the olden days 10 years ago
um we had hard disk drives they looked
like this inside there are some round
discs with a little mechanical arm
moving over it you know you're having a
bad day when the little mechanical arm
actually touches the disc it's supposed
to float above it on a very thin layer
of air it's never supposed to touch it
if it touches it you'll hear it sort of
repeatedly make the Clint debunk clinky
Bonk scratchy scratch noise
then it's time to get the backups folks
or pay a very expensive data recovery
company okay but just there is something
round inside
um and of course these are cavernous in
comparison to the floppy disk
can anyone tell me how much data can be
stored on that floppy disk
ah yes yes
shout out for acorn yeah no appreciate
that this is my Acorn risk PC depending
on how much data's on that disk
I was really hoping someone was going to
say 1.44 megabytes because you are wrong
for two very excellent reasons one one
this is a 720k disc
and the second I'm going to take this
diversion
what happens if you double 720 what do
you get
1440 and these are binary kilobytes
kibi bites we are working in units of
1024 because fundamentally this is built
out of 512 blocks so there was this time
in the 1980s where somebody went
is a mouthful and I don't like that
number
so I'm going to divide it by
a thousand because I don't understand
computers they should have divided it by
1024 because that's how memory and
everything else system works this is a
1.40 megabyte
floppy Drive
1.44 makes no sense because you've used
the binary kilobyte
and then divided it by a thousand to
produce some kind of Frankenstein
creature also this disc is actually from
an Amiga which is why it says workbench
1.3 but Amiga was in a bad place for me
to photograph so I
why is this called a floppy disk
it's not very floppy
this one's slightly more floppy
can we have a shout out for Commodore
this is my Commodore 128d
um this disk drive holds I think about
170 kilobytes
um not a huge amount of storage not
desperately reliable
um but again not that floppy
that's not a floppy disk that's a floppy
disk to quote The Simpsons so yeah they
started out being eight inch and they
were sort of really wobbly in comparison
to the hard or the fixed disk drives
so this is sort of the history of of
storage really
big disk eight inch discs the micro
floppy
um sorry the mini floppy is the one in
the middle and the micro floppy yes the
it's the one on the right it was
invented by Sony in the mid 80s
so a disk operating system has to deal
with these various bits of magnetic
media and what are they well we can
divide each disk surface up into rings
so each ring we call a track and then we
can move some kind of arm across the
disk and we can access the tracks the
tracks are not a spiral they're a spiral
on a CD-ROM as it turns out but on a
floppy disk they're not a spiral because
that will be
annoying to to get back to a repeatable
location
they divided into tracks and we can move
this stepper motor to select a track
and then the mathematicians in the
audience will tell me that
section B is a sector
that is a sector of a circle that is
Maths for you the computer science
people went no no no
we only we only care about the sector
where it crosses the track so actually
it's the little bit where the red ring
meets the blue wedge that's what you
call a sector
in computer science and that is one
small piece of the magnetic medium and
it can be read from start to finish as
the disk spins around
the floppy drive has to do quite a lot
of work because the sectors bump into
other sectors
if the sector only contained your data
how would you tell where it finished and
where another one started
and what if someone was really annoying
and you used a magic word to mean this
is the beginning of a sector okay that
was supposed to be unique and then
someone used that magic word in the file
they saved on disk like the disk was
spinning around and the computer read it
and went oh no startup so you have to
find some
you have to find some combination of
bits that is never used anywhere else
and they use various coding schemes to
ensure that
so a disk operating system is
responsible for managing this because
really you want to think in terms of
files you would like these sort of
ordered collections of bytes that have a
start and an end and they have an order
if you had a file system that gave you
your bytes in your files I've given you
all of the bytes I just haven't
necessarily given you in the in the
right order you would be pretty sad at
your at your operating system
and we need things like when the file
was created how large it is so the disk
operating system's job is to go from
this kind of view it's an abstraction if
you like from Kate's talk um yesterday
we want to think in terms of files but
really the Disk Operating System is
having to go back to this idea of of
tracks and sectors
and then as time has gone on some of
this work has gone into the hard drive
so really you just ask the hard drive
for sector number one million and thirty
three thousand and six and the disk
drive knows how to move the move the
heads and wait for the disk to spin
around inside and then the the flash
drive we saw just sort of emulates the
whole thing
so a Disk Operating System runs
applications on a computer and it
manages files on disk and I think the
other key thing about an operating
system is some kind of portability and
to discuss this let's imagine a world
where there are no operating systems
it's a simpler world it's a more
peaceful World perhaps
so there is no operating system so what
we think of as an operating system just
together with the application which is
good it's just one thing okay so you put
the disk in the computer and you turn
the computer on and it runs the software
which is great simpler I don't have any
Windows updates to do
this is better right
except you're in the middle of using
Microsoft Word which you've just booted
off the disk but now you want to run
Microsoft Excel you've got the word disk
in and not the Excel disk so how do you
exit word and run Excel instead well now
you sort of have to just
I guess swap the disks turn the computer
off and on again
some computers did work this way amstrad
made a line of word processes that
worked in pretty much this fashion it
gets annoying pretty quickly
what happens if I want to take my copy
of Word on disk and run it on a
different computer
okay what I've I've now baked into my
copy of Word all the assumptions about
the computer it's running on I'm going
to plug it into a different one
does it have the same amount of memory
we said there are magical Lockers in the
locker room which are not really storage
they're not really Ram there's some
Hardware devices connected does your
computer have them all appearing at the
same memory locations as my computer
as the author of Microsoft Word I
wouldn't want to have to deal with that
kind of nonsense so I think very quickly
when you imagine this world you accept
that no it kind of makes sense to split
these concerns out it's another good
abstraction applications can live at the
top they exist on some kind of
um
presentation of a machine and then
underneath the operating system can deal
with the nitty-gritty the dirty details
of actually running your code
on a computer so that is briefly what a
what an operating system or a Disk
Operating System needs to do
haven't got out of that away let's take
a a quick run through the history of the
operating system
so I think the first example I could
find
uh yeah I appreciate
not the best name it is the Leo master
program
um what was the first commercial
computer
I think we can say skull for Leo they're
not around anymore does anyone know
where Leo came from or what Leo stands
for
I suppose so you can there's a museum in
Cambridge England called the center for
computing history and they've done a
great research project on this going
back through the archives and talking to
the people who made this machine this is
a computer from J Lyons tea rooms that
is a shop where you can buy tea and cake
why does a shop that sells tea and Cake
in England require the invention of the
world's first commercial computer and
the answer is because they sold a whole
lot of tea and cake
when you have a thousand stores and the
clerk in the store is calling up head
office every day going I need another 16
feet of Swiss roll and three pounds of
tea and 17 gallons of milk someone has
to add that all together place the order
with the dairy send it to the factory we
need six miles of Swiss roll and I need
to divide it up and send it out to all
of my tea shops
and they realize that actually
technology can help them
so they went to the University of
Cambridge to that Ed Sac machine you've
built I want one a bit like that please
and we want to run our uh we want to run
some some applications on it it was made
of six thousand tubes 1200 relays and it
ran an application called Bakery
valuations and that was its job to sum
up how much tea how much cake had been
sold and make sure the shops got their
correct orders and then they realized
well this is working for us and other
people would see that Jay Lyons had
built a computer
can I have one of those
so they went into business and they made
computers and sold them and I believe
this is the first example of a computer
that is sold for commercial business
purposes this is not academic research
this is a computer for doing a job
and then the operating system the Leo
master program by the time you get to
the Leo 3 it can run 12 different jobs
at the same time
so here's an aside I found in automatic
digital computation 1953
um and I'll I'll read it to you because
it's a bit smaller but try and do my
best to impersonate uh
the 1950s news reader style I don't know
if that makes makes sense here but an
unusual feature which has been found
valuable in Fault finding is a
loudspeaker connected to a waveform in
the central circuits of the machine this
loudspeaker makes a noise depending on
the sequence of orders being carried out
and every large program has its own
characteristic Rhythm I love that every
large program does indeed have its own
characteristic Rhythm should the Machine
Stop or permanently go into a closed
loop the fact is instantly apparent in
testing the machine on a simple
repetitive program a single failure is
easily detected as a break or click in
the continuous tone
if nothing else out of this talk I hope
you will go away and think about
plugging a speaker into the central
circuits of your machine so that you can
listen to the regular rhythm of your
program I love that
so let's move on into the 60s the IBM
system 360 operating system runs on that
system 360 we saw earlier uh 1964 uh yes
or no question is the idea of software
being late and rather bloated a new
invention
no IBM system 360 OS was late and rather
bloated and it didn't really run on the
hardware that IBM had already sold
slightly awkward so they shipped another
bunch of operating systems in the
meantime that were a bit smaller that
actually fitted on the 32k machine they
sold you the operating system actually
needed 128k awkward
um system 360 OS kind of lives on today
you can go to IBM and buy a Mainframe
zos will in some senses system 360 OS
compatible
that's a version of the OS that does one
job there's a version that does multiple
jobs there's a version where you don't
even have to decide what applications
you're going to run in advance I know
novel you can choose to run a different
application when the computer's already
turned on
this nonsense will never catch on and
the idea of task switching was actually
to wait to save time a job could get
stuck waiting for a disk so we're like
fine we just park that one and we'll go
and run another one in the meantime
and task switching is actually there to
make the system more efficient it
doesn't feel like it when you've got
3000 Chrome tabs open but there we are
uh multix another big operating system
late 60s so 1969 written for the General
Electric six four five
mini computer slash Mainframe this
machine cost a fortune the operating
system program was kind of a failure and
what do you do when you have a software
program that is spiraling out of control
and looks like it's going to be a
failure
you stand up on a Podium and declare it
as a success we have achieved every goal
we set out to achieve with the multix
program and therefore we don't need to
continue it
which is what they did this machine has
36-bit words
18-bit addresses yeah that's C stuff we
go where Charles 8-bit I heard that
earlier
no no there are definitely machines in
the world where that wasn't true there
are still machines when that's not true
There's no distinction between files and
RAM on a multix machine you say I would
like that file and it says excellent it
is available at these memory locations
there's no sense of read or write
there's just file please sure it's in
memory for you when you access this
memory address I will fetch it is pretty
impressive for 69 Dynamic linking we
have the idea of directories there's a
kernel
it's written in pli
um
the multix we don't hear about it today
but there was a little knockoff version
which you may have heard of
um it's a very small little project from
a university in the in the 60s
I'm glad we don't really use too much of
it today
1969 Bell Labs Thompson Richie
does anyone know what Unix was
originally for
it's a bit good quiz question
they had a multix machine
and they had a game they'd written
called space travel
and space travel cost 75 dollars in CPU
time every time they wanted to run it on
the Mainframe this was annoying because
they liked playing space travel so solar
system simulator
um the Acoustics Department fabulously
well funded the computer science
department not so much
the Acoustics Department had a spare
deck pdp7
pulling out for the digital Equipment
Corporation they're definitely long gone
um it was a spare machine so they can we
have it yeah
broken can we have some spare parts sure
acoustic Department don't care they've
got the money so they basically steal
this pdp7 and they put space travel to
it they can play a game for free happy
days and then they sort of worked on it
a bit and this this operating system was
written in assembler but it had they
were multics people so they sort of did
what maltics did you had hierarchical
file system processes device files that
all came along
then someone wrote a little text
processing utility in it called Roth you
still use Roth today when you open a man
page Man pages are still formatted in
trough the updated version of Roth
still there
annoyingly this hacked together thing
that someone only wrote so they could
play their computer game for free turned
out to be a bit useful and other people
went
it's quite nice can I have one of them
um and unfortunately it spiraled out of
control and it's still here today 50
years later they invented a new
programming language and rewrote their
operating system in C in 1973.
uh Unix family tree or blast through
this because as you can imagine it's
it's really small and really simple and
just goes from one end to the other so
there is Bell Labs research Unix there
are 10 versions of that that's the
original a T and T sort of came out of
bell Labs you get system three and
system five nobody knows what happened
to system four that then span out into
HP ux we can't pull one out for HP
they're still with us just silicon
Graphics yeah uh they had they had their
version called Eric's IBM's AIX still
going Sun yeah that's in our respects to
Sun they had Solaris they were all based
out of system three and system five then
Berkeley did their own thing with the
Berkeley software distribution where the
the first version of Solaris which is
called Sonos you had net BSD open BSD
FreeBSD dragonfly BSD and then you had
Next Step which kind of went nowhere
except it didn't because Mac OS is just
next step
kind of the same thing that's how
Apple's got Steve Jobs back they bought
Next Step they got Steve Jobs and they
just crossed out next step and wrote Mac
OS if you've done any Mac OS programming
the core object in Objective C is an NS
object the NS stands for Next Step
Microsoft had zenix Microsoft were a
Unix vendor
um I was going big guns for them they
weren't interested in DOS because Cenex
has really made all the money and here
is a picture of the family tree and as
you can agree it's nice and simple
okay let's crack on digital research yep
sadly departed they wrote the control
program for microcomputers it ran on
these sort of new 8-bit
um smaller compute so many computers
were the size of a cupboard a Mainframe
was the size of a room mini computed the
size of a cupboard a microcomputer you
could put on your desk mid 70s all of
these companies I think you can pull one
out for pretty much all of those amstrad
well Alan sugar still on The Apprentice
but I'm I think we can pull one out for
amstrad I don't think they've made a
computer recently
um CPM just needs a terminal plugged in
a floppy drive it needs 16k of ram it
only runs one program at once
and it's cleverly split into two pieces
there's a bios that deals with the very
low bits of the hardware and then
there's the operating system which is
the same for every computer so it's the
idea of a portable operating system so
we've even divided our operating system
into half so we can make the OS portable
because the file system
knowing how big a file is how many bytes
it's got what name it is that's the same
on computer a and computer B so why do
that work twice
there is no hierarchical file system it
doesn't support directories you just put
stuff on the disk
um and there's this uh program called
pip which is the copy command
why they didn't call it copy nobody
knows um but if you copy a file to con
it knows you don't really want to create
a file called con you want to print it
to the console and if you copy a file to
PRN you don't really want to create a
file called PRN you want to send it to
the printer so this is where we get this
idea of files that are magical but they
don't exist in PIP
c.msdos I could spend at least a day
talking about the history of the PC it
was a small project from IBM they made
big computers they didn't really care
about this machine it was a side project
skunks works it's kind of an accident
that it took off there was a to do with
digital research here we're going to
supply the OS and for various reasons
they said no so IBM went to Microsoft
who were supplying the basic because
this machine boots basic so obviously it
runs Microsoft basic
and Microsoft went yeah sure we can make
you an operating system that's no
problem and they went out and bought one
um the company they got it from didn't
get a huge amount of money
um IBM then licensed it to IBM and
retained the right to sell it to anyone
else
which turned out to be genius because
somebody else worked out how to make an
IBM PC turns out you can buy all the
same chips from the IBM catalog from
this or from the Intel catalog and if
you just put them on a board in the same
order you've got a PC you just need to
clone the BIOS that that piece of
software Columbia data products were
first
um but they cheated and they copied the
BIOS and IBM spotted them uh people like
Compaq did it better later without doing
a copy but it was compatible and so we
had the era of the PC compatible and CPM
is now doomed CPM was eventually
available for the IBM PC it just cost
three times as much dos was the cheap
option and now con is a special file
because we have directories con works
everywhere not just in the copy program
but anywhere on the system which is why
today in 2022 Windows 11 cannot create a
file called PRN
because it will assume you are trying to
send it to the printer because of
decisions that were made in the 70s it's
wild try it for yourself even file
extensions are ignored you can't even
make a file called aux.txt because aux
is a reserved farming
I want to check I haven't checked I want
to check does this even still apply on
an arm Windows machine I mean this
machine is nothing to do with the PC at
all but these decisions under 70s and
80s come back to haunt it
uh there's a link at the bottom I'm not
going to click it now because we're
short on time meet me in the hallway
track later and I can show you the
hardware and I will play you the worst
video ever made
okay
join me if you dare so what did
Microsoft do they had the Microsoft
Office we had zenix os2
you could spend days talking about what
a mess that was you had the 16-bit
windows line
um you had the 32-bit 16-bit line mid
90s anyone remember the Rolling Stones
doing Start Me Up all the adverts for
Windows 95 and then Windows new
technology which is what we have today
started with version 3.1 and this is
going on now
this is an example of Windows one point
naught it's I think it's ahead of its
time because it's a tiling Window
Manager now what it actually is is an
operating system that can't handle
overlapping windows so they have the
tile because it literally can't draw one
window in front of another somehow this
one the software War I am baffled
um Windows NT sort of has a long story
of its own it's a multi uh platform
operating system it was designed to run
on different processor architectures
mips was first
they wrote Windows NT for mips and then
ported it to Intel to prove that it was
portable it's not really a PC operating
system it is that it is wider than that
um I think we can pull one out for
titanium oh boy let's not go there it is
a very compatible operating system it
has plugins that sort of not emulation
layers but um sort of facades within it
that allow it to appear to be lots of
different operating systems and it was
designed by Dave Cutler who came from
doing the VMS at digital which led to a
small lawsuit because it turns out the
VMS manual and the Windows NT manual
kind of look the same because the same
person wrote both of them and they just
went well that worked I'll do that again
Microsoft paid 100 million dollars to
say sorry and ported NT to the deck
Alpha
um we haven't mentioned Apple big fruit
company the apple one doesn't come with
an operating system it has 256 bytes of
ROM this is enough for a very basic
terminal so you can peacock Peak and
poke bytes in memory that's all it can
do everything else you have to load it
gets Apple basic or Microsoft basic
that's two versions and there's Apple
dos prodos the Lisa was the first Apple
computer with a GUI it was outrageously
expensive it cost ten thousand dollars
in 1983 dollars however it was very
popular at NASA
turns out they have big budgets who knew
they were very sad when the lease it was
canceled Steve Jobs got kicked out of
that project he went to the Macintosh
that shipped in 1984 it cost a quarter
of the price of Elisa the screen looks
very similar but underneath it's it's
not comparable the Macintosh is a much
more cut down system it can't run
multiple programs at once but it's good
enough I know later they ported the
powerpc early Mac OS system looks like
this overlapping windows at least you
know come on you've got to give them
that but you can only run one thing at
once if you open word for Macintosh the
finder will disappear until you've
finished uh Commodore I could spend days
talking about Commodore well their 8-bit
machines had basic the dos didn't run on
the computer it ran on the disk drive
which had its own processor and memory
made the computer cheaper Amiga OS is
fabulous and if you've never used an
Amiga do yourself a favor and go out and
find an emulator and have a poke around
with a meager OS when you think this
system was launched in 1985 it is so far
ahead of what everyone else was doing
there's a multitasking micro kernel
called exec Amiga dos is the OS layer on
top which is actually a port of tripods
which is the Cambridge University
operating system written in bcpl the
predecessor C the GUI was called
intuition and then they bundled some of
this into a ROM they called Kickstart
and then it looked like this this is
workbench 2 but we have overlapping
windows we have multiple applications
running at once they did a demo of this
system at the Lincoln Center when the
Amiga was launched and there was a
ballerina dancing and there was an
animation of a ballerina playing on a
screen above
above above the ballerina and people
just assumed it was a film and no
comprehension that the Amiga was doing
the animation in real time
on this system the icon in the top right
if you click on that and drag it down
you can have a full screen application
running behind the desktop this was a
classic Amiga demo so you'd have this
going and people know Omega is quite
good isn't it and then you just grab
that slide it down and as you slide it
down slowly behind is revealed a full
screen bouncing ball animation it's
going boing boing boing all done in real
time and then you can just slide the
sorry didn't mean to do that slide that
back up incredible people didn't really
grasp what was going on
patari um yeah they're operating today
an 8-bit operating system it was basic
they had toss the OS came from digital
research they didn't stop after CPM they
did the OS for the Atari and again that
was split into BIOS and gemdos and then
you have the gem desktop uh I think this
is an early one and I think Apple Sued
them I mean it does look a bit like
Macintosh system If we're honest I think
there was a sort of a lawsuit proof
version where the windows weren't
movable which is one you you might have
seen I don't know how you can patent
movable windows I don't know
Apple lawyers don't sue me uh Acorn yeah
dearly departed I'm from England uh
acorns based in my hometown of Cambridge
they're made of fabulous range of
machines you had the 8-Bit ones the BBC
micro that went into all the schools
um the operating system was called Moz
and it had a disk file system BBC basic
is the best basic I will not be taking
questions on that go and check it out if
you said it has an inline assembler come
on a basic with an inline assembler
that's pretty neat uh they never had a
16 bit machine they went straight to the
32-bit area with a processor of their
own design
apparently a couple of them went round a
chip company in America and they went
where is everyone and they went no this
is it we do the whole chip design with
three people in it they do it with three
people
we've got three people
we could make a chip
we did
um you've never heard of the chip that
Acorn
um there are Advanced risk machines
division produced uh it became a spin
out was part funded by Apple and it
became uh arm which obviously no one has
ever heard of and isn't you know in
everyone's mobile phone or indeed this
Macintosh yeah so the arm chips we know
and love Came From Acorn on their
initial experiments
with risk OS
um here is risk OS
a quicker side I want to pause on this
one because I love it
it's a busy picture but in the middle
you see save as draw file somebody is
saving a file from the drawer
application
how do they select which directory that
file is going to be saved in
you know what happens on Windows or Mac
OS you get the directory choose a pop-up
and you get to browse the file system
but doesn't your computer already have
one of those you have Windows Explorer
or you have the finder so basically
Microsoft and Apple have given you two
ways to pick a directory that are
different
an acorn went well this is nonsense you
don't need that so to save that file
you go to the disk icon on the left and
then you browse through the folders and
then you drag and drop it to the folder
you want and that is how you choose
where the file is saved
so again I want to reinforce this idea
that these these preconceptions you
might have about how a computer has to
work
are not true a computer does not have to
work like that it is done like that by
convention because people have muscle
memory
um and the people who love risk OS they
really get into it and they can't handle
a Windows machine because it does things
in its own unique way and they learn to
use it and they love it they find it
very familiar very comforting good
muscle memory very efficient
there we go save a file in Risk OS it's
all drag and drop you want to print it
just drag it to the printer
uh Linux I'm not going to well actually
you at this point but it is a kernel and
not an operating system the tools were
supplied by the free software Foundation
the gnu project stands for canoe is not
Unix they provided the compiler the
library shells
um but these days really I like to think
of a Linux distribution as a pick and
mix you know those sweet counters where
you're like I'll have some color bottles
I'll have some some fizzy chews I'll
have some chocolate mice that's what a
Linux distribution is I'll have the
kernel I'll have Wayland I'm going to
have pipe wire for my audio I'm going to
ship this browser so if somebody has to
curate this collection and bring it all
together
key takeaway Linux is not an operating
system it's a Ubuntu is an operating
system because it's had all these bits
picked
so
what is an OS a brief history of the OS
I've got about 15 minutes left by my
clock let's talk about where os's are
today
uh Commodore gone CPM gone IBM
sorry if there's any IBM people in the
audience you're still here with us
really
in Spirit uh Apple early Apple system
Apple carbon gone we are just left with
Windows NT and posix the portable
operating system interface
X
nobody knows what the X stands for and
maybe your web browser is an operating
system you can debate me in the bar
afterwards whether you think that is
true or false
um
give a clue you can boot Windows 95 in
your web browser so
uh
oh yes the good distinction so the point
was uh is your web browser an operating
system is distinct from the discussion
of is it a good idea that your web
browser can be an operating system
that's a good point so what does Windows
NT look like we have kernel and user
space the kernel API is private and you
may only talk to the kernel through the
libraries you are given if you are an
antivirus vendor or doing some other
naughty things and talking to the kernel
directly no that is not allowed and it
will break
um we have executables and libraries we
can load the paths look like this even
though you know it's not the 70s anymore
the hard drive is called C because
obviously A and B are reserved for your
two floppy disk drives that your Surface
Book Pro
um obviously has and the functions in
the library look like this they're in
camel case and they have a weird letter
at the end because Microsoft screwed up
Unicode implementation and the world
still has two copies of every Library
function one that takes ASCII and one
that takes the wrong kind of Unicode so
well done Microsoft
we can't get out of this this is just
the world this is just the timeline
we're in sorry uh posix on Linux kernel
API is public if you want to talk to the
colonel you just execute an instruction
the instruction is syscall the processor
does magic you end up in kernel land
like on the other side of the magic
barrier
um yeah executors with the libraries are
called shared objects the paths have the
slashes this way around you can get into
a discussion about why window slashes
are the wrong way it's
dos two's fault because they already
were using the slash for a command line
option so they went well we can't use
that one so we use the other one from
your point of view that may be the other
way around anyway isn't it really
annoying that a decision an engineer
took
on a whim in 1982 when they added
directories to MS-DOS still bites you in
the backside now
wrong slashes in your include puff some
compilers like it someday and the
functions are very short because this is
from the 70s and you could only have
five characters in a function name so we
have open read write and create because
they couldn't afford the e
uh posix for Mac OS very similar except
the kernel API is private really you can
ignoring the display all the things
underneath this is a Mac OS is a Unix
Linux is very unix-like they're both
posix
um so it's kind of portable Windows is
the outlier
unfortunately the one that sells the
most
uh so what can you do when you write an
application we file handling yeah we can
start stop programs some consoles we
have those text Windows which emulate
the tele types we saw earlier we can
print we can scroll the screen form feed
rolls onto a new sheet of paper Line
Feed rolls the sheet of paper on
carriage return moves the print head the
carriage back to the start of the sheet
of paper that's why you have carriage
return and Line Feed they're two
separate operations but argue I think
Windows got that one right uh obviously
apis for graphics and things networking
memory management there's lots of stuff
we expect an operating system to do
we're going to talk in a minute about
whether my operating system is going to
do these things it's not
okay a brief note on apis and apis
basically the API is the source level
interface you have a function it has
these arguments the function is called
this you can have an API that goes over
multiple processor architectures on an
arm or a PC I both have a function
called open that takes these arguments
so it's Source level
the application binary interface is
lower level this speaks to
when you call a function you can't call
a function on a processor that's not a
thing it can move the instruction
pointer and start executing code at a
different address
so the place you are calling from
the caller has to arrange some stuff in
memory registers or Ram
uh and then when you jump to the core e
the function you are jumping to it has
to look in the same place for the data
the caller is just put if they disagree
on whether the first argument goes in a
register or Goes On The Stack
then you are going to have a bad day
because a will put it on the register
and B will pull it off the stack and
it's not there and it's going to crash
so the ABI is the set of rules about
registers or Stacks what order where
things go
um and this is where we get um binary
compatibility
as an aside don't have time to talk
about it but you really should look up
arm 64 EC because it's fascinating
because they took the Army ABI and they
threw it out of the window this is
Microsoft uh they threw it out the
window because it turns out to be really
annoying when you're trying to run Intel
code on an arm Windows machine and
there's a lot of Intel code on alarm
Windows machine so what they did is they
changed the arm ABI to sort of look like
the Intel one so the use of registers
and the use of Stack is very similar and
then it becomes much more cheap to
bounce from arm code to emulated Intel
code and Back Again
genius idea
and let's talk briefly about language
portability so
we have these operating systems apis but
we know that our Windows opening a file
is create file a and on posix it's open
what is the operating what is the
programming language do well it gives
you a some kind of standard Library
I guess you have the C plus plus
standard Library you python pretty
extensive standard Library go lets you
do file system stuff rust has a good
standard library for doing file system
stuff
so we can write portable source code
which we can then compile for Windows or
for Linux or for Mac OS not the same
binary they have to make different
binaries for each thing that is
technically not true there is an example
on the internet where someone's done
that don't go there
um generally you target a specific
platform a b or c and it's probably
Windows Linux for Intel or Mac OS except
Apple invented the r Max and now you
need to do two kinds of mac and the
Raspberry Pi people are in the corner
going hello um Linux is a thing help
um so you have to Target these different
platforms
um and yeah I mentioned sigwin which
lets you do posix-ish things on Windows
but the semantics don't really match
Fork isn't a thing on windows so yeah
it's sort of an option if you want to
put some stuff
Okay so
there's a blast through what is an
operating system what is a computer
where are the operating systems today so
why did I decide to write a new one what
have I done well
I wanted to write just enough operating
system I wanted to make a computer
a very simple computer and how much
operating system do I need for that to
happen
because what I want is to be able to
load an application I want to walk up to
the machine and say load snake load
Pac-Man load demo tune and have it do
different things so this is not an
embedded system because an embedded
system does one thing a computer I would
argue is a machine where you can walk up
to it and get it to do a thing the
designer did not envisage
now that doesn't count root kitting your
HP printer because the Wi-Fi interface
has got a bug in it that's not what I
mean it doesn't make it a general
purpose computer the intention is
someone can walk up to it and do a new
thing with it that's what makes a
computer
but I wanted it to be understandable
because I think all of the examples of
operating systems we have so far are too
big
they're too complicated
Point me at one person who understands
the entirety of the Linux kernel
you can't because AMD just shipped a
driver update where they added 1.7
million lines of auto-generated
pedophile to describe their latest GPU
the scale of these things is just
colossal
and I think I think we demonstrated
right up at the beginning
you can have an application that is much
simpler you agreed that word five and
word one were applications and they were
running on a machine with very little
Ram that could only run one task at once
there were no windows overlapping
you agreed that was an application so I
want to make that kind of computer again
but I don't just want to dust off the
IBM PC
um I've got old computers they break
they're 40 years old you know electronic
circuits don't last that long they age
they fail
so I want a new computer made with new
parts
turns out buying parts these days is a
bit of a problem there's a whole other
talk we could get into if you've not
chatted to a hardware engineer friend
recently chat to them and say how's that
chip Supply crisis going
um and then watch them SOB
um it's going badly I wanted to make a
machine that was open source and open
Hardware the schematics and the PCB
design for this are on GitHub
the Gerber files that is the diagram of
how the PCB is made that the factory
needs is a job output from a GitHub
action because I believe Hardware is no
different to software I do not check my
XE into GitHub I do not check my Gerbers
into GitHub they are built the keycad
files live there that describe the PCB
and then I generate the PDF schematics
the Gerbers
the bill of materials it is all
generated automatically so here we
talked about why Windows Mac Linux is
wrong they're just too big so what does
neotron OS have we have a single flat
address space like dos but without
segments hooray
the OS API is public and is just
provided in the form of a structure full
of function pointers
so if you want to know what the API is
you just get given
I have given you API do you like it
there's an open there's a close there's
whatever you need it's all in there
I don't have to do ciscals or magic
interrupts it's just call the function
and I will do the work and I will wait
until the work is done and then I will
return there's no background i o there's
no async stuff to just open a file
some time passes file is open super
simple we have executables you can only
load one of them at once
for reasons Russ won't let me do
relocatable code on this platform so
there's just space for one executable in
memory and you load one and you run it
and when it's done it exits you can load
a different one
nice and simple
the paths look like this I've chosen the
Unix lashes because they are the correct
slash but starting with Drive letter C
doesn't make sense because I don't have
floppy drives so I've numbered my drives
so the drives will be zero I am using SD
cards so it's fat so it's 8.3 file names
um
and yeah so you get a table with full of
functions like this this is a function
pointer uh open file is the field in the
struct it is a function it takes a path
the path is a string slice that is
designed to be utf-8 this is a although
I have a four dollar processor and you
know no real Hardware engineering skills
I'm not going to make Microsoft's
Unicode mistakes all of my apis are
utf-8 as they should be the mode is
neither a string nor an integer where
sitting bit seven means that groups can
write to this file but only when it's a
Thursday instead the mode is an object
and the object will have methods on it
for like make it writable make it
readable because this is the 21st
century we can have nice things even
though we're making an operating system
for a four dollar computer the return
type of the function is a result it
either works so you get a file handle or
you get an error you cannot mix the two
up
I'm not going to give you a signed
integer where positive numbers mean it's
a file handle and negative numbers means
it's an error and what does zero mean
so why am I not just building an
embedded system
ah they're boring it's a well-solved
problem there are plenty of people that
can talk to you about embedded systems
and besides I like old computers so I
wanted to make a computer which is why
it has the three color audio jacks the
video is blue the keyboard is purple the
mouse is green this is what a PC looked
like in 1997.
why do I make it open
it's to last I have this you know huge
ego I want this to be a thing that
exists and I want to teach people about
Computing it's why I'm here the thing I
want you to take away from this talk is
that computers do not have to be the way
you see them now they have existed for
far longer than that and you can make a
computer in different ways and in the
future maybe you should consider making
a computer different again they were
different in the past they can be
different in the future
um I know I'm not interested in money we
just give this thing away maybe it's
useful what do you get keyboard Port SD
card audio uh and a video display we're
going to set this up outside it doesn't
work on the projector but we'll be able
to have a look and you can see the thing
boot up in text mode it's not a very
compelling demo at the moment turns out
it's quite a lot of work to get VGA
video out of a four dollar
microcontroller
so there we are we've talked about
make this the smallest possible
operating system so opening and closing
files gonna have to have that uh we have
a screen and a keyboard but we're not
going to do networking
processes and threads locks on RPC
I'm delighted to say that is not going
to be a problem on this operating system
no memory protection if you want to
write over the kernel yeah feel free to
your computer if it crashes press reset
um
okay I know yeah we can we've talked
about portability uh why am I doing it
rust because I just really like rust
it's a nice Community it's a nice
expressive language let's prove it can
be done you know we don't have to make a
1970 style computer in a 1970s style
language there's a bunch of notes on the
ABI and stuff which we don't need to
talk about uh there's a nice 3D picture
of the board
keycard's got some pretty cool 3D
features
yeah there's a whole bunch of reusable
components on the board and that's what
it looks like when it's running so that
is everything we don't have time for
questions but you can door stop me
outside and we can lament the passing of
silicon Graphics thank you very much
everyone